et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
vraiment berger bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous président
délégué du groupe la république en
marche à l'assemblée nationale on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
pascal jalabert bonjour pascal bonjour
du groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france
on commence fort verger bien sûr par la
crise sanitaire emmanuel macron qui est
donc attendu 1 demain à 20 heures
il doit annoncer des mesures pour
alléger ou non le confinement est ce que
vous vous êtes favorable à la
réouverture des commerces dès ce
week-end écoutez nous on le souhaite
évidemment je souhaite d'abord pour nos
commerces qui sont évidemment dans des
situations de souffrance économique
sociale c'est aussi des commerçants qui
voient leur patrimoine pour certains
leurs retraites risquait de disparaître
donc il ya évidemment la volonté de
pouvoir rouvrir des syndicats on espère
le plus tôt possible parce qu'on sait
bien qu à l approche des fêtes on est
dans voilà dans un moment qui est
particulier qui est pas le même que
celui qu'on disait dans le premier
confinement on sait à quel point la
période de noël est crucial pour un
certain nombre de nos petits commerçants
je pensais aux libraires aux marchands
de jouets de prêt-à-porter donc plutôt
ils peuvent rouvrir mieux c'est
économiquement mais mais évidemment il
faut que ce soit dans des conditions
sanitaires et plus respectueuse possible
encore une fois et on sait que les
petits commerces ont travaillé justement
sur ce plan sanitaire de réouverture oui
il est un autre secteur sinistré c'est
la culture le spectacle les théâtres les
loisirs
faut-il rouvrir les cinémas les théâtres
les stations de ski et les complexes
sportifs voir les salles de sport alors
ce sont des sujets bien bien différent
et des configurations mêmes logistique
au ph n est pas très bientôt on va faire
les
bv salle de concert on a permis pour les
notamment le spectacle vivant que les
répétitions continuent que les
résidences d'artistes continue parce
qu'à la fois toute la question de la
diffusion artistique c'est à dire que
les spectateurs puissent avoir accès aux
salles et aussi toute la question de la
création donc ça cette partie là elle a
pu continuer et ça je crois que c'était
absolument essentiel et vous savez à
quel point les budgets ont été
renforcées à la fois des budgets de
crise les budgets de relance 2 milliards
dans le plan de relance et puis le
budget habituel qui est augmenté de 5%
ce qui était rarement arrivé pour le
ministère de la culture
évidemment là aussi plutôt il est
possible de rouvrir mieux c'est avec la
capacité peut-être à réduire le nombre
de jauge à garantir aussi la
distanciation sociale ce qui est
possible
moi je vois bien à quel point les salles
de cinéma de théâtre les salles de
spectacle avait travaillé dans la
première partie de ceux des confinement
la manière avec laquelle ils pouvaient à
nouveau recevoir du public donc il ya
peut-être là aussi des choses à
expérimenter pour permettre que des
publics prioritaires par exemple
puissent être accueillis que les
scolaires puissent être accueillis mais
évidemment plus tôt ils pourront rouvrir
mieux c'est et ça ça vous paraît
possible dès ce week end où c'est trop
toute façon la seule question elle se
rappelle des vacances de noël à noël on
sort on va au théâtre ou au cinéma on
fait du sport c'est un bruit en mai vous
c'est la anglais vous savez bien que les
conditions sanitaires elles sont
extrêmement différentes dans une salle
de sport par exemple et dans un théâtre
dans une station de ski et dans une
salle de cinéma à la question c'est
comment on fait pour limiter encore une
fois le nombre de personnes dans une
jauge comment on fait pour éviter le
brassage parce que c'est ça la plus
grande difficulté c'est la manière avec
laquelle on circule on a bien vu que la
difficulté à laquelle on est confronté
aujourd'hui qui est la vraie différence
par rapport à la première vague c'est
que toutes les régions sont concernées
dans la première vague finalement il y
avait quelques régions qui étaient très
fortement mobilisés concernés et
d'autres vers lesquels on pouvait
évacuer des personnes qui étaient
concernés qui devait aller en
réanimation là tout le monde est
concerné parce qu'il ya eu le brassage
justement de cet été donc il ne faut pas
que la à nouveau on est des brassages de
population trop important qui viennent
remettre une pression excessive sur
l'hôpital que veut dire que pour parler
aux soignants vous en faites témoignent
aussi régulièrement vous
et bien qu'ils ne peuvent pas revivre ce
qu'elles ont vécu en premier mais quand
vous nous parlez de brassage de
population ça veut dire qu'on lève pas
la règle des 100 km tout de suite et on
l'a lèvent quand ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir être extrêmement vigilant encore
une fois sur qui a le droit de se
déplacer dans quelles conditions se
déplace et aussi encore une fois on le
sait sont nos interactions sociales qui
vont définir la circulation ou non du
virus alors je sais bien que ça paraît
un peu fou de se dire qu'à noël quand on
se retrouvera pas pouvoir se prendre
dans les bras
c'est ce que va être le rôle des
politiques est de le dire mais son
absence de retrouver selon je sais qu'il
faut limiter le brassage et d'un boudin
c'est important que les français se
retrouvent en phase i à noël damman
important je crois que c'est un enjeu
social sanand un enjeu aussi
psychologique
on voit bien qu'il ya une détresse
psychologique dans le pays qui existent
qu'il ne faut pas minorer qui est liée à
l' isolement qui ait provoqué notamment
pour les personnes âgées qui elles
vivent réellement le même confinement
que celle qu'elle avait vécu dans la
première vague et donc il faut
absolument évidemment permettre ces
robes à nice avec des 100 km on l'a lève
pour les vacances de noël je l'espère je
l'espère et encore une fois peut-être
que les choses pourront se dire
peut-être pas demain mais peut-être
donner des perspectives pour les
semaines qui viennent mais on ne le dira
jamais assez c'est le virus circule du
fait des interactions sociales et
d'ailleurs quand vous parlez dans les
ehpad à des soignants des directeurs
d'ehpad ils vous disent finalement
celles et ceux qui ont contracté le
virus ou qui sont qu'à contacter le
contractent pas à l'ehpad
mais le contracte dans l'environnement
familial donc ça met une pression
importante sur chacun d'entre nous mais
qui est malheureusement nécessaire
le premier déconfinement il était trop
rapide du coup j'avais besoin d'avoir
des perspectives
c'était complètement inédite tout d'un
coup la france se retrouve confiné
pendant huit semaines et il fallait un
moment qu'on se dise ce confinement là à
la fois il sert à réduire fortement la
pression sur l'hôpital public ce qui a
fonctionné on a bien vu la décrue
extrêmement spectaculaire que ça a
provoqué mais on avait besoin d'en
sortir tous humainement socialement
économiquement psychologiquement c'est
ce qui a été fait et c'est ce qui a été
fait aussi et de manière progressive
canton dé confine la population
française qu'on rouvre pas du jour au
lendemain les bars ou les restaurants
ouvrent pas du jour au lendemain les
lieux culturels ou les espaces de
loisirs là aussi on l'a fait de manière
très progressive
par contre en effet il y avait 1
elle besoin aussi de se retrouver il y
avait un tel besoin d'interaction
sociale que peut-être que ça ses revenus
aussi trop rapidement quand on voit qui
a encore des fêtes clandestines qui
existe des gens qui d'ailleurs se font
de l'argent sur sur ces fêtes c'est
encore le cas ce week-end
c'est à la fois prendre des risques pour
soi mais surtout prend des risques pour
les autres
or la crise et la sortie de crise elle
repose non seulement sur la conscience
qu'on a du risque pour nous mêmes mais
du risque qu'on fait courir aux autres
et ça c'est toujours plus difficile à
faire accepter on a déconné
collectivement c'est ce qu'aurait dit
jean castex selon des propos rapportés
hier par le journal du dimanche qu'ils
ont mais derrière ce on sait les
français le gouvernement
vous savez je crois qu'il y avait un tel
besoin de se retrouver qu'à un moment
évidemment on ne peut pas empêcher les
gens d'avoir envie d'un nouveau circuler
et de vivre tout simplement comme on le
comment on vivait auparavant
la difficulté c'est qu'on doit apprendre
à vivre avec le virus sur un temps long
moi je trouve que c'est assez
remarquable d'ailleurs la discipline
collective dont on a tous fait preuve et
dont on continue à faire preuve mais qui
a des conséquences qui sont encore une
fois des conséquences économiques
sociales il ya d amortisseur très
puissant qui ont été posées mais les
conséquences psychologiques
les amortisseurs même si vous mettez en
place des soutiens ils sont extrêmement
difficiles à pouvoir être générées et
donc oui peut-être qu'on a en effet eu
tout simplement la nécessité et le
besoin d'être ensemble et s'est testé ce
besoin d'être ensemble ils se conjugue
pas du tout avec cette maladie qui
progresse grâce à ça et donc c'est là où
il va falloir qu'on soit tous
extrêmement vigilant mais ça c'est pas
un décret et vous dites est pas une loi
à noël avoir le même comportement qu'on
a eu cet été c'est en tout cas on pourra
pas vivre le même noël que celui qu'on a
vécu les années précédentes mais si on
veut être ensemble parce que c'est quand
même ça l'enjeu c'est qu'on puisse se
retrouver si on veut que nos petits
commerces sauf si on veut que la vie
culturelle reprennent le plus vite
possible dans le pays
on le sait ça dépend avant tout de nous
mêmes alors justement pour casser les
chaînes de contamination le porte-parole
du gouvernement libyen il faut isoler
davantage de voir le rendre obligatoire
ostiz allmand vous y est favorable
il le dit à titre personnel je n'étais
personne je comprends que gabriella
talent le disent parce que on a une
véritable difficulté sur notamment
toutes les personnes qui sont qu'à
contacter normalement quand vous n'êtes
qu'à contacter vous devez pouvoir vous
isoler et c'est rarement le cas
malheureusement on a souvent les
personnes qui nous interpelle qu'il mais
je comprends pas
environnement professionnel à quelqu'un
qui me dit qu'il est qu'à contacter et
pourtant il est revenu au bureau et
travaille à côté de moi donc ce qui crée
évidemment un risque mais surtout ce qui
crée en plus une incompréhension
donc il faut impérativement que les
personnes qui soient cas contacts qui
ont été du coup signalé par l'assurance
maladie a des possibilités pour les
isoler je comprends qu'il ya plein de
configuration ou c'est
extraordinairement compliquée parce que
dans votre logement par exemple c'est
pas possible de pouvoir vous isolez de
votre famille donc il ya des prises en
charges qui ont été mises en place pour
vous puissiez lettre à l'hôtel
évidemment que en charge à 100% je
comprends que c'est absolument pas
confortable par contre c'est absolument
nécessaire parce que si vous n'êtes qu'à
contacter c'est à dire que vous êtes
potentiellement à risque et que derrière
vous restez dans l'environnement
familial habituel dans l'environnement
professionnel habituel mais c'est là
clairement ou en effet les chaînes de
contact et bien malheureusement mais
est-ce que clairement vous êtes
favorables à l'obligation et à des
sanctions pour ça en tout cas il va
falloir sont soit probablement plus
strictes pour permettre qu'il ya un
suivi
aujourd'hui malheureusement il n'y a pas
forcément ce suivi donc c'est même pas
la question de la sanction mais c'est
finalement est ce qu on vous rappelle
pour vérifier où vous êtes est ce qu on
vous rappel pour vous demander dans quel
environnement familial vous êtes est-ce
que vous habitez dans une maison qui
vous permet d'être isolé ou est-ce que
vous êtes dans un petit appartement avec
une femme un mari et deux enfants vous
n'êtes pas dans la même configuration
est ce qu'on vous a proposé des
solutions alternatives d'hébergement qui
permettent de garantir votre iso
d'audition premier responsable et c'est
déjà ça c'est qu'on vous interpelle
quand vous interroge sur la manière avec
laquelle vous vivez comment on peut vous
aider comment peut vous accompagner et
qu'on vérifie on rappelle pour voir si
oui ou non vous avez respecté ce avec
l'employeur ou s'ils jouent le jeu parce
que on l'a parfois vu il ya une pression
pour que les personnes reviennent au
travail là où elle pourrait être en
télétravail voire même que des gens qui
sont gays à contacter soit présent donc
il ya aussi une grande vigilance de la
paille tu voulais servir et les
employeurs pour voir en tout cas un
emploi ne peut pas mettre en danger
évidemment la santé de celles et ceux
qui travaillent dans son environnement
et quand on est interpellé par les
salariés qui nous disent je ne comprends
pas moi je pourrais être en télétravail
l'on me demande quand même d'être
physiquement présent alors que nous
évidemment on tient le discours inverse
il faut qu encore une fois chacun joue
le jeu dans sa paix cela dit un cas
comme ça ne dure pas si on se fait
tester faut-il tester encore plus
massivement qu'on le fait les tests sont
très mal dans notre pays vous le voyez
bien aujourd'hui ils sont plus d'une
extrême rapidité
on peut avoir certains résultats en
quelques heures d'autres en 24 ou 48
heures au plus donc pour le coup il ya
une rapidité des tests et surtout toutes
celles et ceux qui ont besoin d'être
testée dès qu'un compteur les cas
contacts sont testés systématiquement et
sont prioritaires évidemment pour être
testés et l'autre actualité c'est la loi
sécurité globale et particulièrement son
article 24 1 qui fait débat il a été
votée vendredi par l'assemblée nationale
dans une version un peu remaniée un
gérald darmanin est venu à l'assemblée
nationale il a garanti la liberté de la
presse christophe castaner a fait hier
une tribune dans le journal du dimanche
sur le même sujet est ce que quand même
il ya un recul du gouvernement et de la
majorité sur cet article il ya une
clarification parce que
vraisemblablement il y avait une
incompréhension sur les intentions qui
était celle de la majorité puisque
c'était une proposition loin qui était
portée et qui est toujours portée par
une histoire et jean-michel fauvergue et
donc il fallait clarifier et cette
clarification elle a permis de dire que
clairement évidemment en aucun cas et en
aucune manière on était là pour entraver
le travail de la presse et des
journalistes
la question qui se pose c'est comment on
arrive à garantir un équilibre entre le
droit absolu d'informer de montrer donc
ce qui se passe y compris dans des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
et dans le même temps comment on fait
pour pas répondre ce que répond jean luc
mélenchon à savoir de dire aux forces de
l'ordre
écoutez si vous n'êtes pas capable
d'assumer les risques liés à votre
métier fait autre chose parce qu'on ne
peut pas accepter d'avoir des forces de
l'ordre qui sont menacées qui voient
leur propre famille être menacés parce
que qui voudra demain être forces de
l'ordre l'état n'est pas en capacité de
les protéger
donc c'est cet équilibre là protéger la
presse son intégrité sa capacité à dire
à montrer à interpeller et protéger
aussi celles et ceux qui assurent notre
sécurité au quotidien c'est cet
équilibre là j'ai pour l'art on a vu
qu'il a été trouvé c'est eh oui parce
que dialogue la garde des sceaux le
garde des sceaux à eric dupond-moretti
dire on peut pas poursuivre en droit
pénal français des gens pour une
intention est ce que vous dites cet
article il ne passera pas l'obstacle du
conseil constitutionnel
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
parce que certains nous demandait
justement que cet article on leur
accroche au code pénal
nous on l'a pas fait pour cette
raison-là notamment c'est qu'évidemment
pour une nantes
on considérait que c'était ça n'avait
pas forcément de sens c'est justement et
s'était même extrêmement risquée d'un
point de vue des libertés des libertés
publiques et c'est la clarification
aussi encore une fois qu'on a apporté g
genton et j'ai interpellé été interpellé
aussi par des journalistes par des
médias qui à un moment où vous voulez
avoir des clarifications très clair sur
ce qu'on allait faire ou pas sur
l'intention en l'occurrence qui était la
nôtre à partir du moment où on a
clarifié les débats ont été très longues
terminé vendredi très tard dans la nuit
plus tôt samedi matin d'ailleurs
donc ça a permis aussi je pense de
préciser quelles étaient les intentions
du gouvernement et de la majorité en la
matière en aucun cas et en aucune
manière mais jamais on ne mettra en
cause la liberté d'informer et quand
j'entends celles et ceux qui disent
qu'on en serait attentatoire aux
libertés publiques
une des premières lois qu'on a voté dans
cette majorité c'est la sortie de l'état
d'urgence
et souvenez-vous à l'époque des débats
que ça avait généré en disant que nous
étions presque des gens dangereux parce
qu'on ne souhaitait pas faire entrer
l'état d'urgence dans le quotidien des
français
il se trouve que là on a une autre
urgence qui a été l'urgence sanitaire et
vous voyez bien qu'à chaque fois c'est
sur des périodes très courtes s'est
renouvelée systématiquement après un
débat parlementaire
le premier ministre est également
présent justement pour faire en sorte
que ce ne soit pas notre état normal et
habituel qu'on ne s'habitue pas à être
sous des reins qui sont des règles
dérogatoires
il n'empêche qu'il ya eu des
manifestations ce week-end il y un appel
de 33 personnalités qui avaient voté
mais emmanuel macron a retiré le texte
comment vous entendez l'appel l'appel il
est plus large à la peine et les 33
personnalités et concernent à la fois la
loi sécurité globale est à la fois la
loi séparatisme a raté ce sont de loin
et ces personnalités justement et je
n'aurais d'ailleurs qui pour l'instant
n'a même pas été présenté en conseil des
ministres donne donc la coller ou c'est
sur des intentions connaît quand même
pas mal de détails
ça m'embête
il faut que vous bougiez encore sur ceux
sur ce texte ne m'attendais c'est pas
parce que vous avez un appel de
personnalités et cédric muller enfin
cédric villani il n'a pas voté la
confiance au gouvernement
au dernier va donc c'est pas tout à fait
une personnalité c'est un homme qui est
aujourd'hui un homme politique est dans
l'opposition
donc c'est pas tout à fait pareil quand
même et après c'est pas parce que vous
avez quelques personnalités mais et je
remets pas en cause leurs compétences
sur leur domaine qui vous interpellent
en disant faut changer la loi
pour autant on doit la changer vous avez
33 personnes ne vous avez aussi une
opinion publique vous avez aussi des
français vous avez aussi des forces de
l'ordre des policiers des pompiers qui
au quotidien vous interpelle et méritent
aussi d'être parfois écoutez moi c'est
que j'habite un département on a connu
magnanville magnanville ce sont deux
policiers qui ont été assassinés chez
eux devant leur enfant
donc ça existe ça existe d'avoir des
forces de l'ordre qui sont menacés après
encore une fois notre enjeu c'est
comment on garantit un équilibre qui a
toujours été un équilibre sous tension
entre liberté et sécurité entre liberté
d'informer de montrer au public ce qui
se passe et il faut qu'on ait des
journalistes évidemment qu'ils fassent
leur travail en toute indépendance et
qui montre d'ailleurs tout ce qui s'est
passé ces dernières semaines montrent
bien à quel point il ya une indépendance
absolue de la presse dans notre pays et
tant mieux donc cette liberté là et en
même temps garantir la sécurité et la
protection de celles et ceux qui
permettent d'ailleurs de garantir ces
manifestations un mot sur une autre loi
roberge et celle de l'audiovisuel avait
été rapporteur de cette loi qui a été
abandonnée alors elle a été abandonnée
entendait l'air mais coûte que james
wilkie a été un peu de dispatcher dans
différents textes du coup que devient le
contenu de cette loi lors ce qui est
certain c'est que c'est une loi qui est
importante c'est loi qui est importante
dans un secteur qui en plus en crise
aujourd'hui l'audiovisuel la création
audiovisuelle le cinéma qui va permettre
justement de renforcer les moyens qui
sont accordées à la création
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans un premier
temps en lien avec le sénat où on à
transposer des directives qui permette
enfin de faire en sorte que les fameux
gafa en particulier netflix disney
amazon qui aujourd'hui sont des
plateformes qui plaisent aux français eh
bien elle contribue bien
au financement de la création dans notre
pays on est les premiers d'ailleurs en
europe à avoir transposé ces directives
donc ça c'est fait indépendamment de la
loi qui doivent poursuivre qui doit
permettre à la fois d'avoir une
régulation plus efficace parce que vous
avez justement ces financements des
plateformes il faut faire en sorte
derrière de bien régulé l'organiser la
lutte contre le piratage
parce que malheureusement dans ces
périodes de confinement s'est largement
reparti à la hausse et piratés ça veut
dire aussi moins de moyens pour créer
moins de moyens pour les chaînes pour
acquérir des droits qui sont droits des
oeuvres des droits sportifs
et puis moins de moyens aussi tout
simplement pour les créateurs pour les
auteurs pour les artistes interprètes
donc tout ça ça veut dire salle
d'enchères en 2000 vers le virtuel
français pour mais ça met clairement en
danger l'équilibré c'est à dire que le
premier pillage c'est le piratage des
oeuvres et c'est pas ringard de vouloir
lutter contre le piratage c'est tout
simplement nous assurer que les auteurs
les créateurs les artistes interprètes
les producteurs soient rémunérés pour
les oeuvres qu'ils nous permettent de
voir et auquel nous permettent d'avoir
accès donc ça c'est ce qu'on veut mettre
dans la loi en 2021 on veut absolument
aboutir en 2021 quand vous dites
elle sera reprise cette l'audiovisuel ça
veut dire qu'il y aura une l'audiovisuel
dans le port avant la fin du quinquennat
c'est avant la fin du quinquennat même
on espère en 2021 c'est la volonté et de
l'exécutif et du parlement en accord
d'ailleurs entre l'assemblée et le sénat
on souhaite aller vite et on souhaite
d'autant plus aller vite qu'il y a
urgence à soutenir le secteur culturel
dans cette crise on la fait encore une
fois sur des moyens budgétaires
renforcée mais on doit le faire aussi
sur des outils qui permettent de mieux
réguler et de mieux soutenir qu'elle est
abandonnée il y aura une nouvelle eau
les habituels on termine en parlant de
politique le blanquet donc alors une
enquête de nos confrères de libération
révèle que le mystère de les coacher
seul aurait financé et contribue à créer
un syndicat lycéen
une commission d'enquêté demandée le
ministre lui même est favorable vous
même vous pensez qu'il faut une
commission d' enquête pour faire la
lumière sur tout ça déjà si le ministre
l'a dit c'est à dire que s'il y a eu des
subventions qui a été octroyée et qui
n'ont pas été utilisés comme elle aurait
dû être utilisé parle de 5000 euros
alors il faut qu'on comprenne exactement
ce qui s'est passé il a demandé qu' en
effet les investigations donc il est
très au clair par rapport à tout ça moi
ce qui m'a interpellé
cglu évidemment l' enquête de libération
section ces trois pages enquête en fait
il n'est jamais fait référence à jean du
sales blancs car à aucun moment les
personnes qui témoignent avec des
témoignages qui sont contradictoires
parce que d'autres fondateurs de ce même
mouvement se sont exprimés pour dire que
vous n'avez pas compris les
interrogations qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui
et bien en fait à aucun moment ils ne
parlent nommément jean michel blanc car
en disant que c'est lui qui les a
rencontrés qui les aurait
instrumentalisé ou que sais-je
donc moi je suis quand même assez
interpellé part ça je vois que ça
intervient aussi dans un moment
politique qui à un moment où jean michel
blanquer s'est exprimé de manière très
claire s'est exprimé aussi pour mettre
en accusation ce qui n'avait pas soutenu
des valeurs fondamentales comme la
laïcité à l'école qu'il a mis en
accusation aussi notamment jean luc
mélenchon qui l'a accusé d'islamologie
schiste mais je reprend évidemment mon
compte ce terme parce que
malheureusement on voit cette lente
dérive antirépublicaine de la part de
jean luc mélenchon et des insoumis donc
il ya une pression politique qui est
mise sur sur jean michel blanquer
et puis je vois aussi que finalement
c'est l'on donne un peu le sentiment que
les lycéens n'aurait pas le droit de se
syndiquer
et si c'est pour soutenir la une action
qui peut être une action réformatrice
ça va quand on est d'extrême gauche de
se syndiquer et qu'on est lycéen mais
par contre quand c'est pour
éventuellement soutenir une action de
réforme du lycée de référent du
baccalauréat alors là tout d'un coup
tout de suite il ya des interpellations
qui naissent ce serait le bon candidat
jean michel blanc coeur aux régionales
pour la belgique est essentielle
je crois parce que je crois que c'est
quelqu'un qui a profondément réformé
l'école quand on parle d'égalité des
chances qui a été fait sur le
dédoublement des classes en ré
paieraient plus est fondamental il va y
avoir une grande réforme d'ailleurs sur
l'éducation prioritaire que là encore il
va pouvoir porter ce qu'il a fait est
aussi je suis vraiment les valeurs de
l'école ministère lors de serra s'est
passé avec agnès buzyn est ce que c'est
le mot que je vais leur a pas qu'il soit
question qui les fuit la cité sont son
ministère dans les semaines qui viennent
ou dans les mois qui viennent il ya une
campagne qui va se passer qui sera très
certainement la porte et vous le savez
bien ce sera probablement pas en mars
mais plongeront juin j'ai fait ça
n'impose pas d'être six mois matin midi
et soir en campagne avec en plus des
modalités de campagne qui du fait de la
crise sont bien différentes des
campagnes électorales qu'on a pu
connaître vous nous imaginez
difficilement dans un mois ou dans deux
mois de faire des tournées de réunions
publiques
donc je crois qu'il sera très différent
et campagne qu'on va vivre dans les mois
qui viennent mais je crois surtout que
par rapport aux valeurs qu'il incarne et
aux réformes qu'il a conduite oui ce
serait le bon camp du oui pourrait être
candidat ministre en même temps moi je
le souhaite en tout cas
et merci beaucoup merci aversion envers
g on va regarder votre une pascale avant
de se quitter la une bouillie revirement
[Musique]